your diamondback starter tonight the
right-hander taylor widener is fourth
start since his most recent return from
a groin injury now you'd like to think
he's starting to round into shape a
little bit anybody coming off the
injured list it's going to take a couple
of starts to get your command back
use all three of his pitches a fastball
slider change up combination he's going
to have to keep it in the yard as we
mentioned in the brimley breakdown he
surrendered eight home runs in 36 and
two thirds and he's facing the team
that's hit the most home runs in the
national league that includes chris
bryant their newest acquisition who
homered yesterday and his giant's debut
is in there again tonight mike istremski
leads it on
that stays fair at first base for
christian walker
well here comes the newest giants chris
bryant required from the cubs at the
trade deadline he homered in his first
game as a giant yesterday in san
francisco next pitch to him and a swing
of the miss and he is down on strikes
and that's out number two here and
whiteners started off strong
slider fell right off the table here's
brandon crawford is the o2 pitch and a
swing and a miss and a nice first inning
for taylor widener he strikes out
bryant's swinging he gets crawford
swinging after retiring his strip ski on
an easy ground ball to first one two
three right hander out there for the
giants anthony diesclefani his first
season in san francisco 10 wins a 3-1-0
era already the best marks of his career
yeah he's been really good against the
d-backs here is catel marte
bounce to first for big darren ruff down
there cal hooted third that's the first
three unassisted at first calhoun at
third now with one man out for us druva
cabrera three-two pitch
slider struck him out swinging so the
strikeout in the strikeout situation i
mean that's not a hanger that's by
design that's where he wants it here is
carson kelly the former cardinal eight
home runs
and a 383 on base
he swings and chops the ground ball to
third one big hop to bryant the throw to
first
right there chest high to rough
[Applause]
[Music]
it toward the right field corner he's at
it again they'll have to settle for one
boy hit that ball hard no chance for two
your strengths again over there pretty
quickly two down runner aboard here is
nick ahmed runner at second two down
here the pitch swung out and misty
struck it out with a hard slider for the
outside
inning
here is donovan solano to lead off now
for the giants as we go to the third
inning in phoenix
that one hit hard into left field
there's the first giants hit and peralta
was playing so far
toward the gap he had a long way to go
that turned into a pretty good play by
david peralta one out solano still at
first and here comes lead off man mike
kosremsky delivers and yes crushes one
deep to right field patios pelota
way back into the bleachers and he did
not get that one as high as he wanted it
and jastremski just hit a laser beam
down the right field line but very much
fair and his 18th homer of the year has
given the giants a two-nothing lead it
leaked a little bit out over the plate
and that's all it took 407 feet and your
strips can do it right out of bed first
bryant to strike out victim in the first
1-2 pitch
swing a little tapper up the first base
side nobody's covering in first base
belatedly heading there for the bag and
not getting there in time as widener
diving safely in there chris bryant with
a base head total middle block by water
i mean he just stops going over to first
base two balls two strikes two outs
pride at first brian runs in a swing and
a miss posey down on strikes in the
inning comes to an end well two
strikeouts in the first
second and third innings for
taylor widener and a drive into right
and that's a base hit over to cut it off
yastremski he'll hold cabra to a long
single as
calhoun races around to third boy that
ball is ripped
it really was ripped a chance for carson
kelly first and third two outs
that one goes right through buster here
comes calhoun as drooble moves up
diamondbacks on the board a slider that
got to the backstop here's the pitch
ground ball to short to crawford here's
the throw to first
inning over
he went full on the stremski and lost
him with the base on balls now it's the
3-2 to bryant to get on three and two
and he lost him so back to back one out
walks
two on for crawford with one out of the
inning third time through the order is
always a tough one for a pitcher here it
comes crawford rips one into right field
base hit coming to third and stopping
there yastremski the ball got out to
calhoun so quickly that yastremski had
no chance
the bases are loaded for the giants on
crawford's base hit the giants have the
bases loaded with a 2-1 lead here in the
fifth inning here's the pitch it is low
ball for a slider and a great take by
posey
it's three to one giants yostremski
comes in to score
posey gets credit for the run batted in
i i don't believe there are many
right-handed hitters who could lay off
that pitch
so after the strikeout by the pitcher to
lead off the inning it's gone walk walk
single walk and here's dickerson who's
over two
giants with a chance to make some
serious noise the pitch is blasted to
right field this one is gone
a grand slam for alex dickerson second
grand slam the giants have hit against
this pitcher this year
and that was just obliterated it's 7-1
giants what a shot 437
feet and i think that ball landed in the
bleachers before the people out there
heard the crack of the bat and the
giants have blown this game open pitched
to renick is in the air to right hit it
pretty well this ball is going to go
pinch it home run reddick two-run shot
it's seven to three a second as a d-back
he's
trying to ramrod that curveball into his
arsenal in this inning he's thrown two
of them one was a base hit to left and
one was a josh reddick home run to right
still just one out here in the fifth
inning you know he wants to give him the
chance for the win he's going to leave
him in there for the moment churron
homer here could make it a two-run ball
game and cabrera swings high fly ball
deep right field and that one is out of
here it's a two run game two two run
homers in the inning for the
diamondbacks seven to five gabe kappler
gambled two scenery tries to go front
door with and just a little lazy and
cabrera says that's where i like them so
the giants were ahead seven to one and a
big chunk of that lead is now gone and
wilbur flores who came in as part of a
double switch now in the ninth spot
one-two pitch that one is hit high and
deep to left field this one is gone
wilmer flores
first at bat of the game and he goes
deep
a hanging slider home run number 14 for
wilmer
and the giants get one of those runs
back it's eight to five giants ellis
banning in the pitcher spot faces
lowered in one out and a 0-2 pitch to
drew ellis ground ball down to third
that's a fair ball bryant won play at
first and he gets he out at first base
iran will score to make it eight to six
two outs now runners move up at second
and third a base hit by christian walker
can tie the ball game
and a line drive that's going to tie it
down into the left field corner
in his marte right behind him cabrera
and christian walker has tied this game
at eight on a two-out double and gabe
kepler is going to make the pitching
change the giants were once ahead 7-1 in
this game
3-2
right on the outside corner strike three
call
that was a perfect pitch here's his 2-2
posey rips it down the left-field line
that is a fair ball into the corner
brandon crawford's going to come around
to score buster posey's gonna end up at
second it's 9-8 giants still nobody out
now they're going to walk slater
intentionally and bring up stephen
dugger
duggar rips it into right field that'll
get it done posey will come in to score
slater digs around for third stephen
duggar comes through ten to eight giants
two one
on the ground to short what a backhand
pick by crawford and that will do it the
giants survive in phoenix